et pour commencer les informations
insolites on prend la direction de la
vallée de Chevreuse vous allez nous
parler de folie la voir qu'est-ce que
c'est alors c'est une association qui
s'appelle hélium qui regroupe un certain
nombre d'artistes il se trouve que du 27
mai au mois de septembre jusqu'au
journée du patrimoine la vallée de
chevaux et plus précisément les lavoirs
des villages de la vallée Chevreuse vous
pouvez être investis par 35 artistes 32
l'avoir alors ils vont sûrement se
disputer un peu il y en a pas assez mais
on se débrouille et c'est financé il
paraît il faut le dire par la Région
Île-de-France et puis le PNL et puis les
communes c'est sur 27 communes et ça
s'appelle fulli la voir donc le lavoir
est au centre du travail de l'artiste
qui s'approprie le lieu alors vous aurez
différents matériaux des fautes la photo
du sculpture qu'est-ce qui existe pas
sur aidez-moi Land Art etc vous aurez
aussi alors le 28 mai si vous voulez
voir les artistes ils seront tous chacun
en
alors la voir vous aurez aussi après
d'autres événements qui vont se greffer
à savoir des vernissages comme ça dure
longtemps tous l'été des vernissages des
concerts des spectacles il faut vraiment
regarder le programme ça va être très
riche il y a quatre c'est organisé en
quatre parcours 3 sur les Yvelines 1 en
Essonne pour vous donner une espèce de
logique de de cheminement certains
l'avoir sont assez proches les uns des
autres donc faut y aller soit à vélo
soit à pied et puis et puis l'avoir
c'est c'est un endroit qui est important
enfin qui était surtout important
autrefois une fonction sociale de
mystique ça peut parler aussi de la
condition féminine de l'environnement
naturel voilà voilà mais beaucoup de
choses et donc ce sera à découvrir
jusqu'au 17 septembre jusqu'au 17
septembre complètement il est à partir
du 28 mai très bien très bonne date
aussi faut préciser pour votre deuxième
information à celui de Véronique vous
êtes aussi intéressé à l'une des plus
cette mise en prison le 17 juillet l'été
jugé par fou qui est un ville qui a fait
pas lui mais les autres révolutionnaires
ont fait disparaître cette lettre parce
que on voulait pas croire qu'elle était
indépendante on voulait faire croire que
c'était un complot de des Girondins et
en fait non elle était vraiment
indépendante et elle ce qu'elle disait
aux Français c'est attention vous voyez
comment ça tourne ressaisissez-vous
récupérer vos libertés arrêtons la
violence elle elle était pour la paix et
elle a mis des lois et de la paix quoi
et donc bah c'est sacrifié et elle
disait de toute façon tuant un homme
j'en sauve 100.000 et cette lettre aussi
elle est très émouvante parce qu'elle
est donc de sa main il y a des titres
d'épargne qu'est-ce qu'elle avait
accroché caché dans son corsage et un
acte de naissance aussi parce qu'elle se
dit sur le chemin est malheur au monde
sera qui je suis et elle dit bien je
suis seule à de responsable dans mon
acte n'allez pas embêter mes parents ni
ma famille et et voilà donc elle est
exécutée et cette lettre va être mise en
vente comme j'ai dit entre 80 et 5000
euros sachant que la lettre on l'avait
déjà parlé de Robespierre à Danton est
parti à 225 000 euros voilà ça peut
s'envoler c'est un c'est un document
extrêmement touchant très bien et vous
vouliez également nous parler des
prochains Vy
la joie le plus viré l'honneur de
recevoir Michka sayas pour la deuxième
fois jusqu'à Zahia c'est un journaliste
spécialiste de musique rock il officie
tous les soirs sur France Inter il vient
de sortir un livre qui s'appelle very
good trip du nom de son émission et
c'est un enfant de la Vallée de
Chevreuse imaginez-vous donc il va venir
il était très attaché à ça il a grandi
dans la vallée des Chevreuse il restait
très attaché à sa maison d'enfance il y
vient souvent il va nous parler de son
nouveau livre et puis de la saison de
l'été prochain sur France Inter très
intéressante passionnant et bien vous
retrouve la semaine prochaine bah avec
plaisir Régine merci à très vite